teşekkür ediyorum herkese Burada
olduğunuz için Sizlerle olmak burada
olmak
çok heyecan verici
Şimdi
burada videoda neler gösterdiğini
bilmiyorum Çünkü o şeyi ben izlemedim
ama tabii az çok tahmin ediyorum YouTube
kanalından vesaire
Burası benim uzun hayatım Uzunca bir
dönemini geçirdiğim yere çok yakın
Evimiz bahçelievler'deydi Burası bizim
için hani ne derler komşu semt gibiydi
çok gelip gittiğimiz bir yerde O yüzden
kendime evimde hissediyorum bir anlamda
okuduğum okulda yine bahçelievler'deydi
bu başlığı duyduğum zaman
Bence diğer konuşmacılarımızla aynı şeyi
hissetmiştir
Bu benim olmam gereken yer dedim yani
burada konuşmacı yapmayacaksanız En
azından dinleyici olarak geleyim dedim
Çünkü tam olarak beni anlatan bir cümle
kullananlar kaybolanlardır
hatta biraz da bulanlar kaybedenlerdir
her seçiş bir vazgeçiştir
bazen bazı şeylerden ödün verdiğin zaman
fedakarlık yaptığın zaman bir şeyler
değişir buraya bir girişimci olarak
çıktım ama bir başarı veyahutta bir
başarı hikayesi anlatmak için çıkmadım
Bence biraz ters köşe olacaksınız En
azından
beklentileriniz itibariyle Bir de tedx
konuşmalarının kendine has bir şey
vardır böyle sürekli mottolar sürekli
bir mesaj bir değil mi Hani böyle reals
yapılacak kesitler falan Ben de bence
onları da bulamayacaksınız
Burada iki tane Ustam var benim ben usta
çırak kültürüne çok çok önem veriyorum
ve
solda gördüğünüz Dedem rahmetli Emin
diye bilinen Anadolu'nun son ahilerinden
biriydi ve ben onun tezgahında 3 yaşında
onun imalathanesinde ilk hatırladığım
anlar oradan anlardı Sağdaki de babam
bu hayatta iki tane veyahut da 3 tane ya
da En kötü ihtimalle bir tane Usta seçin
kendinize Bu benim size bir abi tavsiyem
olsun bir ustanız olsun kulağınızı
bükecek
Zamanı geldiği zaman şöyle ensenizde
şaplatacak Çünkü bizim ustalık
geleneğimizde bunlar var Hani bazen
diyorlar ki Usta çıraklık işte deyince
şey gibi ya mentor Mental ilişkisi mi
kardeşim bu binlerce yıllık bir öğreti
Yani sen mentör Menteş istedin şurada
Yüz Yıllık varsa var Bizim usta çırak
geleneğimiz binlerce yıllık bir gelenek
Ve şuna çok önem veririm
sizi şikayet edilebileceğiniz biri
olmalı kim olursanız olun en Tepe
makamlara da gelseniz birisinden
korkmanız lazım bizim oralarda
Erzincan'da şey derler kork korkmazdan
utan utanmazdan derler birinden
korkacaksın Mesela ben 40 yaşıma
yaklaştım babamla sahada gördüğünüz 20
yıl hayatımızın 20 yılı beraber
ortaklıkla geçti
ve şimdi Artık babam işten uzaklaştı
emekli moduna geçti Ben hala çok
korkarım babama birisi beni şikayet
edecek diye ve çok mahcup olurdum çok
utanırım
şimdi önce hikayenin yaldızlı
kısımlarından bahsedeceğim
bana bunu karıştırma demişlerdi
demeseler de karıştırmayacaksın büyük
ihtimalle
Evet Babamla beraber 92 Erzincan
depreminde Biz İstanbul'a göçtük ve
97 yılında ben internet sitesi keşfettim
97 yılı internete Türkiye'nin internetin
Türkiye'ye yeni geldiği dönem şu
kırmızıdan da çıkmadığı gibi durum var
değil mi Ben duramıyorum burada ama
Biraz da bana biraz daha geniş bir
kırmızı ayırsaydınız yani
şimdi 97 yılında internet sayfası
yapmaya başladım depremden gelmişiz
İstanbul'a Küçük Emrah gibi dolaşıyorum
O zaman iki kardeş geldi depremde iki
kardeştik İstanbul'a geldik 4 kardeşiz
dört erkek kardeşi en büyüğü internet
sitesi yapıyorum internet sitesi de
şimdi evlerinizde internet olmadığını
hayal edin bilgisayar olmadığını hayal
edin edemiyorsunuz bizim için evde
internet o zaman için bir hayaldi
internet kafeye gidip böyle bir saati
internet açtırmak dünyanın en büyük
mucizesiydi oraya gidip dünyaya
bağlanıyordu ve ben o zaman hayalim yani
bu Ben buradan paramı kazanacağım
ekmeğimi kazanacağım anlamıştım Çünkü
muazzam bir dünyaydı bir şey sayfa
alıştırıyorsanız ve bir başka dünyanın
bir başka ülkesinden birisi o sayfayı
okuyor veyahut da form dolduruyor
2002 yılında üniversiteyi kazandığım
sene itibariyle bir firmada yazılımcı
olarak işe başladım 2 yıl orada çalıştım
2 yılın sonunda bir yazılımcı Junior
yazılımcı Müdürüm bana bir projeyi
teslim et dedi ki Bu proje hafta sonu aç
Ben Alaçatı'ya kaçıyorum dedi
ve bana hiç daha önce Yapmadığım bir şey
emanet etti Ben o işi yaptım
ve olmadı yani yaptım ama yapmaya
çalıştım olmadı Pazartesi oldu ben
bekliyorum ki benim müdürümü kovacaklar
bu çocuğa niye bu işi bıraktın gittin
beni kovdular
ben böyle çok rahatım yani nasıl olur
Ben elimden geleni yapmışım müdürüme
sesimi yükseltmişim diye beni kovdular
Fakat benim böyle bir travmaya girecek
psikolojimin bozulacağı bir bir
Psikolojik destek alacak bir imkanım ve
o zamanlar için şartım yoktu o yüzden bu
problemin bu kovulmanın yanından geçip
hayatına devam etmek zorundaydım ve
babamın yaptığı babam o zaman Bir araçta
bir printer icat etmiş bir mucittir Yani
aslında
bir imalat yapıyor ama dışarıya
Çalışıyor yani kendisini tanıyan yok
firmasına bilen yok kapısına tabela yok
Ben de Ertesi gün zaten dışarıdan babama
destek oluyordum ertesi gün gittim ve
kendime
babamın firmasını satış müdürü diye
kartvizit bastırdım
ve takım elbiseyi giydim Babamla beraber
gittim babam bana bakıyor ilk işim
görevim babamın sigara kül tablosu
dolduruyor ben onu boşaltıyorum bir daha
dolduruyor ben onu boşaltıyorum babam
demiş ki Burayı söyleyemeyeceğim
kamerada bizi de çok kullanılan bir
çocuğa yönelik bir şeydir bu
eşekle başlayan eşekle biten
sanki demiş bana Microsoft Genel Müdürü
takım elbise de geliyor iş yerine iş
yerinde Babamla beraber ikimiziz
telefon çalıyor ben bakıyorum İyi günler
diyordu diyorlar Bir yetkille
görüşeceğim bir ürün için fiyat
isteyeceğim bir saniye aklıma oyun
diyorum beklemeye alıyorum Biraz daha
kalın bir sesle ne kadar çıkarsa artık
Buyurun ben satış müdürü Ömer ikinci
diye açıyorum telefonu babam telefonlara
bakıyor Bazen ben okula gidip geliyorum
Bu arada
Babam Babam Ha şu şeyi öğretmeye
çalışıyorum baba diyorum Bak burada ben
senin oğlun değilim ben Ömer Bey
ofise giriyorum ki babam telefonla
konuşuyor fiyat sakın söyleme diyordu
Çünkü benim babam maliyetine bile olsa
verir
babama arıyorlar ne kadar Bu diyor ki
onu Ömer Bey ile konuşmanız lazım tamam
diyorlar peki ürünü görebildiğimiz tabii
diyor Ömer'le yolluyorum
baba diyorum hadi güzel başladık niye
tamamını getiremedik
ve
Dostlar 7 sene Biz babamla gece gündüz
perpa'da Bir küçücük dükkanda 7 sene
geçin
perpadaki güvenliklere Gidin Sorun hepsi
beni tanırlar Çünkü pazar dahil Dükkanı
açan tek biz vardık
her Çünkü pazar günleri Oraya girmek
için izin kağıdı almanız lazım O 7 yılın
sonunda Biz gece gündüz çalışmamızın
meyvesini aldık ve 2009 yılında defnet
yılın genç girişimi Ben de yılın genç
girişimcisi olarak ödül aldım
beni yani daha doğrusu herkes beni tanır
defnet deyince
babamı Birçok yerde Ömer'in babası diye
tanıyorlar ve bilin ki sahnede şu anda
karşınızda baba değil oğul varsa bu
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle babanın
başarısız
Çünkü babam bana hep şu şeyi söylerdi 25
yaşında yarım milyon euro olup iş almak
için bir firmaya gidiyorum
babamın bana söylediği Sen git şey et
yani o şeyi hala daha onu kullanır Yani
onun tam şeye sordum Google Translate
gibi bir şey
babam hep bunu söyledi bir ürün yaptı
getirdi masama bıraktı sen Bunu şey et
dedi gitti Onun adını koymayı
markalamayı sayfasını oluşturmayı
pazarlamayı satmayıp bana bıraktı ve ben
onun sayesinde satış pazarlama grafik
tasarım birçok şey öğrendim
ve çok zor bir şeydir kendi yaptığı
ürünü ortaya koymak Daha sonra kendi
yaptığı kendinden Mamül Bir evladın
sözünü dinlemek Hatta en sonunda
anahtarı ona teslim edip çıkmak Biz çok
şanslıyız çok kısmetliyiz güzel bir
şekilde o devir teslimini yaptık ve 20
yıl ve ben hayatımın ileriki
aşamalarında babam çok şükür Başımızda
bir gün gelip
Eğer ki Allah sıralı ömür verirse bir
gün gittiğinde ben şuna çok şükredeceğim
Biz 20 yıl babamla Omuz Omuza Beraber
mücadele et Beraber çalıştık Bu benim
için bütün kazanılacak paralardan bütün
kazanacak servetlerden çok daha kıymetli
Evet
burada bir Dergiye beraber çıktığımız
İşte o takım elbise benim
sonra ben bu hikayeyi Yani şöyle şöyle
sanki Microsoft Genel Müdürü dediği
hikaye Microsoft genel müdürlüğünü
anlattım bir gün
ve
dostlar
sonrasında
2009 yılında Ben Türkiye'de yılın genç
girişimi sürdülü aldım dediğim gibi yani
el yapar ağız övünür derler değil mi
hocam Öyle bir söz vardır Ben övünen
taraf anlatan taraf olduğum için
ödülleri ben aldım
ve sonrasında yılın genç girişimi söz
üyle bazen konferanslara çağırmaya 92
depreminden işte Küçük Emrah hikayesi
nereden başladık bu arada benim
hayatımdaki ilk müşterim Güngören
sınırları içinde bir dükkandı minicikti
şu an Güngören'in en büyük firmalarından
bir tanesi Az önce onun önünden geçtik
kitabımı isteyenlere pdf'ini internetten
mail atanlara göndereceğim mailimi en
sonunda var O kitapta da geçen ilk firma
ismidir Efor diye bir firma önünden
geçtik geldik
ve sonra benim ilerleme Hikayem başladı
gazetelerde yazmaya başladım televizyon
programı yapmaya başladım Aziz sancar'ı
canlı yayında bir buçuk saat konuşturdum
Ne bileyim talk show yaptım Bir anda ne
olduğumu şaşırdım bende yani tanınan
bilinen birisi olmaya başladım medyada
televizyoncu değilim televizyon programı
yapıyorum gazetelerde yazmaya başladım
İşte kitap çıkarttım üniversitelerde
konferanslara gitmeye başladım
ve tanınan birisi oldum siyasetin
dikkatini çekti bu teklifler gelmeye
başladı Ben de şu rahatlıkla reddettim
ya dedim Nasıl olsa ileride yapacağım
şimdi Acelesi yok
ve
akabinde de
2015 Kopuş bu tüm bütün bu yaptığım o
ünlü olma tanımma hamlelerinin
tamamından Koptum Çünkü evlendim
Çok acı bir şeydir bakın hocam burada
ben evlendim ve eşime şu cümleyi Çok kez
kurduğumu hatırlıyorum tartışırken ben
Ömer Ekinci
sonra eşim beni bir güzel eğitti
otur diyor oturuyorum
kalkıyor kalkıyorum
bildiğiniz bir şeyden geçtim yani
terbiye sürecinden geçtim ve bana
Aslında
evinde iyi bir baba eşine iyi bir adam
eş olmayan hiçbir kimsenin gerçek bir
adam olmadığını öğretti
sonra dostlar
bir evladımız oldu ilk yıllarımız çok
zor geçti bizim asaf'la şu anda 7
yaşında 2 gün önce doğum günüydü
buralarda birazdan sahneye de koşabilir
koşmuyor da bilir
ve ilk yıllarınız bizim çok zorlu geçti
bir teşhisler koydular sonra öyle olmadı
Anlaşıldı bizi oradan oraya böyle pinpon
topu gibi gönderdiler ilk okuldan böyle
bize çocuğu poşet de verdiler Çocuğunuzu
götürün işte buraya oyun sağlamıyor
falan filan
meğerse çocuk Üstün zekalıymış
mesela saymaya çok ileri kadar saymaya
kendi başına farklı dillerde kendi
başına saymayı öğrendi
işte diyelim yüzün üzerine kadar kendi
başına saymayı öğrendi sonra okula
gönderdik çocuğu bir geldi ona kadar
sayıyor
Çünkü ona kadar saymayı öğretiyorlarmış
okulda fazlasının çocuk yanlış olduğunu
görmüş
ve
oğlumun o ilk zamanlar ki zor durumu
yahut da bizi zorlayan durumu bizim
acemiliğimiz Biz üç yıl dört yıl kadar
çok yoğun bir şekilde evde vakit
geçirdik onlarla davetler gelmeye devam
ediyor Bir tarafım hala ünlü bir tarafım
hala davet edilen taraf ama bir tarafta
Babayım sonra her gelen daveti tartıya
koymaya başladım
dedim ki beni davet ediyorlar şu
programa şu organizasyonu Ankara'da
İstanbul'da sonra şunu tartmaya başladım
beni Acaba saat öğleden sonra ikiden
üçten sonra hangi davet sahibi hangi
organizasyona sahibi böyle camda
bekliyor
hiçbir organizatör beni böyle camda
beklemiyordu O yüzden her seferinde ben
oğlumu tercih ettim
çünkü en üstteki makamlardan gelen
davetlerde bile
özür dileyerek dedim ki kusura bakmayın
benim oğlum ben eve gitmeden uyumuyor O
yüzden Siz İstanbul'da olduğunuzda
görüşebiliriz
ve
[Alkış]
Allah'a çok şükür her gün saat böyle
Sabah erkenden kalkıp iki üç saat
beraber vakit geçiririm Şimdi şunu
diyebilirsiniz ya bu kadar çocuğunla
odaklanır bu kadar kaç dakikamız var
orada
bu kadar ev odaklı bir hayata geçtikten
sonra İşlerin nasıl gittiğini Nasıl
işlerin nasıl yönettin
oğlum doğduğu zaman ben kendime bir söz
verdim dedim ki ben daha doğrusu oğlumun
haberini aldıktan sonra şöyle bir karar
aldım
Ben çocuğuma banka ya değmiş faize
değmiş bir para kursağından
geçirmeyeceğim şirketimizin haliyle
kredileri var borçları var o zaman için
kredi çok ucuz bütün şirketleri Hadi
Kredi alın Aman uğraşmayın ne gerek var
Kredi ile alırsanız dedikleri dönemde
Ben 2015'lerde banka kredilerini
kapatmaya karar verdim 1 yıl içinde
dedim ki şu saçların bembeyaz olsa bu
kredileri kapatacağım çok şükür Bir
senede bankacılığın hiçbir inanmıyordu
buna
kapatamazsınız sizin bilançonunuz buna
yetmez diyorlardı ve hepsini kapattık ve
Oğlum doğduğu zaman ben banka kredinin
tamamını kapatmıştım sonra Tabi o
eğitimler vesaire çok masraflı çok
maliyetli Çok para kazanmam lazım bazen
evden çıkıyordum Oğlum evde Çığlık
çığlığı ağlıyor
sokağa iniyorum arabaya biniyorum çığlık
sesi kulağımda
sokaktan çıkıyorum caddede
değiştiriyorum ilçe değiştiriyorum
kulağımda hala aynı ses
iş yerine gidiyorum hala oğlunun sesi
ama ben çalışmak zorundaydım Hatta en
verimli çağlarımı Yaşadım ve oğlumu o
şekilde bırakıp akşam İşimi bitirdim
biraz evime koştuğum o dönemde Hayatımın
En bereketli en güzel işlerini yaptım
şirketin %500 büyüdü son 5 senede
tamamen oğlumun bereketi tamamen faizi
bırakmanın faizsiz hayata geçmenin
bereketi ve bugün Geldiğimiz noktada
Bugün bankalar şirketlere kredi
vermiyorlar
O zaman o bollukla o şeyle fazla fazla
Yağdıran bankalar bugün şirketlerde
elini çekmiş durumda beni emin olun ki
oğluma verdiğim oğlum için verdiğim O
söz korudu
bir gün bir hocaya götürdük işte Dediler
ki çok iyi bir profesör var harvardı
işte Çocuğunuzu görmek istiyor daha
doğrusu işte görmek istemiyor da
görmemizi istiyorlar aradakiler Bir de
böyle tavsiye eden çok olur şu hocaya
gidin bu hocaya gidin arada döner
durursunuz gittik
oğlumu gördü hiçbir şey söylemiyor bir
saat boyunca böyle baktı baktı Ben
sorular soruyorum Hocam diyorum işte biz
ne yapmamız lazım oyun mu oynamamız
lazım yok oynayamazsınız ne bileceksiniz
oynayacaksınız Hocam diyorum
eğitime mi götürelim yok ki eğitim
Türkiye'de nereye götüreceksiniz hocam
en sonunda şu soruyu sordu Hocam biz
Oğlumuzu daha
normal bir çocuk olmaya doğru mu
yönetmeliyiz yoksa kendi özelliklerini
daha başarılı kullanan bir çocuğa mı
dönüştürmeliyiz Bana şunu söyledi
beyefendi dedi sizin çocuğunuz hiçbir
zaman normal bir çocuk olamayacak
ben o anda şunu söyledim İçimden gelen
oydu hocam dedim sizi normal çocuk
dediğiniz benim iş yerim Hemen bir
okulun yanında normal çocuk dediğiniz o
birbirinin Kafasını taşla kıran
öğretmeninde bağırıp çağıran hakaret
eden Sokakta her türlü pervasızlığı
yapan normal çocuklar mı o
benim çocuğum Öyle olsun zaten
istemiyorum Benim iki tane büyük hayalim
vardı oğlum doğmadan önce oğluma mektup
diye bir şiirim Var YouTube'da bakın
oğlum değil Eşim bile yok o zaman o
zaman bile hayalimdi o oğlumla iki şey
yapmak 20 yıl boyunca boks yaptım
oğlumla beraber yengeç çıkmak ve boks
yapmak istiyordum hayalimdi bu
bu hayalimi gerçekleştiremedim Çünkü ben
oğluma ne zaman yumruklarımı kaldırsam
oğlum gülerek mutlulukla gözlerini Çünkü
gülerek bana sarıldı benim oğlum şiddet
sevmiyorsa şiddetin ne olduğunu bile
anlamıyorsa normal çocuk olamıyor kusura
bakmayın
bir hayalim daha vardı sahneye oğlumla
beraber çıkıp konuşmak
bu hayalim de gerçek olmadı ama
gözünün içine baktığımda Benimle her ne
kadar konuşamasa da her istediğini
anlatamasa da ben Onun gözünün içinde
Dünyada hiçbir zaman hiçbir yerde hiçbir
kimseden göremeyeceğim sevgiyi gördüm
Bana bunu gözleriyle anlattıktan sonra
sözüyle konuşmasıyla anlatamasa ne olur
çok önemli mi bu
toplumun size normal diye dayattığı şey
ne biliyor musunuz onun yanında oluyorsa
Eğer çocuk kendisi rahatsız olduğu için
çocuk normal olmuyor o kucağına almak
istediği zaman gelmiyorsa bu çocuk
Asosyal diyor ya ben de gelmek
istemiyorum senin kucağına
Yani onun bir karakteri bir isteği
arzusu olamayacak mı sen onu gıcık gıcık
diye yanaklarını aburup cuburacaksın
bunu istemiyor diye Asosyal mi olacak
Derler ki herkes tek gözlü olsaydı çift
gözlü olanlar engelli sayılacaktı
ve biz oğlumdan üçüncü dersi aldım
toplumun dayattığı normalleri kabul etme
ve biz bunu kabullenince çok mutlu
olmaya başlıyor
anladım ki Bir Adam evinden içeri
kapısını kilitlediği zaman
eşiyle oğluyla birçok televizyon
programında birçok ünlü birçok başarılı
insanı konuk ettim yüzlerce ünlü hepsini
tanıdığınız İnsanlar bir tanesi hariç
hiçbir tanesi evime sokmam biliyor
musunuz
sizin Evinizdeki samimiyet tabağınızdaki
lokmanın bereketi tadı birçok
imrendiğiniz insanın tabağında yok
Evinde yok
çok başarılı insanlar var tanıdığınız
çok büyük işler yapanlar konuşup gerçek
dertlerini Dinlediğiniz zaman sizin
hayatınızın daha huzurlu daha mutlu
olduğunu görüyorsunuz ve ben
çok böyle önü açık bir hayatta çok sade
dükkanında oturan akşama kadar
ürünü satmaya çalışan akşam olduğunu
Saat 5 oldu mu da koşa koşa evine giden
bir adama dönüştüm
keşke bunu ben yapmasam
yani Ben yapamıyorum bunu anlamış olduk
Bu da bizim aydınlığa sürecimiz oldu ben
oğlum doğduğu zaman zannediyordum ki
Dostlar baba olduğun zaman ben her şeyi
bilenim o hiçbir şey bilmeyerek dünyaya
gelen Ben ona Bildiklerimi öğreteceğim
o büyüyecek Ben de görevi tamamlayacağım
meğerse hiçbir şey bilmeyen Benmişim
meğerse Ben ondan öğrenmek için o gelmiş
dünyaya O benim mürşidinmiş o doğduğu
zaman ilk defa kucağıma geldiği andan
itibaren Bunu fark ettim
bizim o Büyümüş ve o mükemmeldi
dediğimiz hali insanın doğduğu hali
mesela Bir doktor bir Hocam yakın
zamanda bu yaşadıklarımızı anlattım ve
bana şunu söyledi Ben burada inmek
istiyorum ya
bunu demedi Ben diyorum buna
Dostlar bana dedi ki sizin de
imtihanınız buymuş dedi
bir anda şimşek çaktı Beynimde
ya
güçlü olan benim Bunu çıkıp sahnelerde
oğlumla yaşadığım zorlukları
anlatabiliyorum dostlarımla
dertleşebiliyorum oğlumun benden başka
dertleşebilecek kimse yok
Ya ben onun imtihanıysam
o gün farkına vardım ben onun
imtihanıyım Çünkü o ne kadar bana öfke
de gösterse şiddet de gösterse bana bir
şey olmaz ama bir baba kötü bir babaysa
o çocuğun Bütün hayatı zehir olabilir
Demek ki ben onun için iyi bir imtihan
olmalıyım ben ona iyi bir baba
olabilirsem onun İmtihanı ben kendi
imkanımı geçmiş olurum hocam dedim ben
onun imtihana O benim imtihanım değil
Eğer verebilirsen ben onu İmtihanı
olacağım ve benim imtihanım onun
sayesinde belki başarılı olmuş olacak
ve çünkü
küçük yaşta çocuklar görürsünüz 8
yaşında 7 yaşında
annelerin babaların tamamı çocuklarına
şikayet ederler Siz hiç Küçük bir
çocuğun annesinin babasının arkadaşına
şikayet ettiğini gördünüz mü
güzel yemeği Benim annem yapar en güçlü
Benim babam diye onlarla övünürler
çocuklar Bizden çok daha sağlamlar çok
daha Dostlar
arkanızı bir çocuğa sımsıkı dayıya
bilirsiniz asla sizi yarı yolda bırakmaz
ama bir anne baba çocuğundan çok şikayet
ediyor
İşte o zaman İmtihanı kaybetmiş oluyor
imtihanını kazanamamış oluyor
o kadar korktum ki ondan sonra o kadar
utandım ki Halimden şikayet ediyor muyum
bunu bana hediye edene düşünün ki bir
çocuk normal bir çocuk herhangi bir
ailenin bir çocuğu var bir de işte
buraya çıkan bir sahneye çıkan bir
konuşmacı cebinde Bir Elmas saat var
çıkartması lazım kime verir o en değerli
şeyini burada kime güveniyorsa ona verir
değil mi en güvendiği en tanıdığı kimse
ya Allah en özel kulunu bana güvenmiş
bana emanet etmiş ve ben bundan mutluluk
duymak yerine gurur duymak yerine
şikayet etmiş o kadar acı ki bu Bunu
fark ettim ve
İşte bu aydınlanmayı bu aydınlanma da
değil Bu arada bunun sadece bir başında
belki ikinci belki üçüncü aşamasındayım
Ama bu böyle devam ediyor
burada sosyal medya hesaplarım var bir
tane kitabım var senin yolun diye onu
Arzu edenlere mail atanlara PDF olarak
gönderelim aranızdan bir kardeşim var
dedi ki bana Türkiye gazetesinde
yazıyorum
abonelik sistemine geçti şöyle bir daha
durduk yere abone olacak Yani benim
yazarım içinde o kadar para değmez
dedim ki abi dedi Senin yazıları
okuyamıyorum dedi Şimdi onu her yazımda
editöre gönderirken o kardeşinin cc'ye
koyuyorum bütün yazılarımı İlk o okumuş
oluyor kitaplar satmak için değil
kitaplar daha çok satılsın diye değil
daha çok okunsun diye yazılır Ben
isteyenlere mail olarak pdf'nin tamamını
göndermek istiyorum Burada beni bu kadar
sabırla dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ederim sağ olun var olun
[Müzik]